und nach einer nacht schlaf dazwischen
können wir jetzt mit einem sprechender
mit dabei gewesen ist ich begrüßung
phoenix tagesgespräch johann wadephul
stellvertreter fraktionsvorsitzender der
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
größte nach berlin wenn ich es recht
sehe in ihr abgeordnetenbüro erwartet
1982 sind sie in die cdu eingetreten und
wenn ich es recht gezählt habe haben sie
bisher zehn kanzlerkandidaten miterlebt
fünfmal kohl einmal stoiber viermal
merkel
was ist das wichtigste was jetzt der
aktuelle unions kandidat mitbringen muss
ich habe sogar schon als schüler
miterlebt den kampf zwischen strauß und
albrecht also ich habe zwei mal erlebt
dass cdu und csu
diese frage gerungen haben jetzt auch
und daraus kann ich insgesamt nur sagen
das wichtigste ist dass man geschlossen
beieinander bleibt das eben das nicht
geschieht was zuletzt in ihrem beitrag
gesagt wurde was verletzungen gibt dass
es verbündete gibt das ist auch
beschädigte politisch geschädigte
personen gibt denn wir haben jetzt zwei
wirklich sind geeignete kandidaten beide
sind ministerpräsidenten beide bringen
regierungsverantwortung mit und beide
brauchen wir in jedem fall also auch
derjenige der es jetzt nicht wird wird
für die union sei jetzt in bayern sei es
in nordrhein westfalen auch bundesweit
eine enorm wichtige rolle spielen
und deswegen ist jetzt der prozess sehr
wichtig dass man mit einer unterstrich
dass man miteinander ringt das auch der
ein oder andere sagt was er wem erzielt
aber dass das um geschädigten geschieht
er war vor zwei wollen nur einer darf
auch die unionsfraktion war hat er einen
brief bekundet 50plus ex-abgeordnete sie
wollen mitreden heißt was würde das ganz
konkret heißen was wäre ihr votum für
welche personen das sind einige kollegen
die sich schriftlich noch mal zu wort
gemeldet habe und natürlich auf den
wichtigen umstand hingewiesen haben dass
wir nicht alle maschinen wieder
kandidieren
die personen sind gm 299 direkt beim
kreisen in ganz deutschland antreten
und den unmittelbarsten kontakt mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern haben am
unmittelbarsten auch von diesen prozess
betroffen sind
sie müssen nämlich diesen kandidaten in
ihren wahlkreisen vertreten und sie
müssen mit diesen kandidaten wenn man
erfolgreich ist und dafür kämpfen wir ja
als bundeskanzler dann zusammenarbeiten
also das ist so fertig ist das fraktion
eine rolle spielt dass man auch so hört
es wichtig ich halte nichts davon jetzt
öffentlich bekannt zu geben
für wen man ist ich sage wir haben zwei
hervorragende kandidaten und wir
brauchen zwischen diesen beiden eine
entscheidung im persönlichen gespräch
und herrn sag ich dazu auch wenig zu den
richtigen halt
und jetzt haben sie das richtige
stichwort gemacht im persönlichen
gespräch bis zu diesem sonntag haben
beide immer öffentlich erklärt wir
bereden das miteinander und kommen mit
einem gemeinsamen vorschlag und dann kam
es gestern anders warum hat herr laschet
nicht das erstzugriffsrecht der größeren
schwester benutzt ja weil er vollkommen
zu recht gesagt habe wir müssen es
miteinander besprechen und das tun die
beiden ja dass das nicht in einem
gespräch geschieht ist auch eigentlich
klar weil es sehr sehr wichtige frage
für sie persönlich sondern für die
unionsparteien insgesamt ist aber sie
reden miteinander sehr ausführlich und
das haben sie auch geschäftsführende
fraktionsvorstand in meinem details
geschildert das für und wider
auch die situation der union insgesamt
geschildert wir sind in einer situation
dass wir sicherlich vorne liegen aber
das nicht sicher ist sondern eher
unsicher ist ob wir die nächsten
bundeskanzler wieder stellen
und wir wollen natürlich in eine
position bekommen wir deutlich über 30
prozent bekommen und wo klar ist dass
die union wieder den bundeskanzler
stellen dass wir dieses land ziehen
können welcher koalition auch immer und
das geht eben nur im gespräch
miteinander meine ungeduld ist
mindestens zu rufen wie jährige also ich
hätte mir natürlich auch schon gewünscht
dass es schon geklärt ist aber den kopf
ist auf 48 oder 72 stunden
das wäre ungefähr ihre zeitliche messer
hatte er warte vor denn auch sie haben
richtig noch mal festgestellt und das
haben wir beide auch erklärt
mehrstündige gespräche haben sie bereits
geführt das kann ja nur bedeuten dass
herr söder hat nicht den vortritt
gelassen
hat nun hat er seine bereitschaft
erklärt allerdings auch die bereitschaft
zurückzuziehen wenn er keine breite
unterstützung der cdu fände
wie groß wäre denn das risiko für die
union mit herrn seda anzutreten ich
glaube wir haben hier eine ganz andere
situation ich habe ja mal 1980
bayerischer als franz josef strauß
konnte man in deutschland gar nicht sein
und auch edmund stoiber die man ja viele
preußische qualitäten zugesagt hat war
natürlich ein altbayern also ein
typischer bayer und das ist natürlich
schon bei markus söder anders ich das
mal die konfession die große bedeutung
wie vor 20 30 jahren aber man könnte
natürlich schon sagen mit markus söder
haben wir einen evangelischen franken
und das ist schon eine person die
durchaus auch in anderen regionen
deutschlands
viele menschen der union anspricht seine
zahlen das muss man ganz nüchtern fest
halten sind eindeutig in allen umfragen
seit längerer zeit stabil besser als
diejenigen von armin laschet das ist in
einer demokratie von einer bedeutung das
kann man gar nicht negieren aber in la
strada wenn uns auch gezeigt dass er ein
das größte bundesland gewinnen konnte
und erfolgreich mit einer stimme
mehrheit in ihren kann das heißt das ist
schon mögliche regierungskunst es auch
geschafft die grösste partei die cdu
hinter sich zu bringen also es ist eine
ganz ganz schwierige abwägung bayer
haben hervorragende qualitäten und
insofern würde ich sagen mit beiden
kandidaten kann man überall deutschland
antreten wenn ich das andere noch einmal
mit zurück wäre die situation früher war
erst albrecht und angela merkel waren
norddeutsche protestantische
nordostdeutsche mit armin laschet haben
wir einen katholischen rheinländer der
wird sicherlich in bayern oder im
südlichen deutschland auch gut ankommen
für eine kandidatur der christlich
sozialen oder christlich demokratischen
union also in der tat es ist eine knappe
sache und es ist so dass beide
kandidaten in ganz deutschland
unser potenzial gut ansprechen können
aber die zahlen für markus söder sind
natürlich schon ein punkt ja und das
sind möglicherweise auch einen beleg
dafür was man auch alle beobachten
konnten das ist relativ wenig
öffentliches beispringen für die lasche
bewerbung bisher gegeben hat aber das
kann sich ja heute ändern ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre einschätzung
informationen heute im phoenix
tagesgespräch johann wadephul
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der unionsfraktion im deutschen
bundestag dankeschön